- L'été, c'est la saison des
vacances, mais c'est aussi
celle des expositions agricoles.
Au fil des ans,.La semaine verte
en a visité plusieurs,
à commencer par celle
de Regina, en 1971.
♪ ♪ ♪
Cette année-là marquait le
lancement d'Agri-Vision,
la grande foire agricole
dans les Prairies.
- C'est un début magnifique
avec au-delà de 2000 têtes
de bêtes à cornes et au-delà
de... tout près de 1000 porcs.
Puis moi, je crois que ça
s'imposait dans l'Ouest
canadien.
- Madame, accepteriez-vous que
votre mari diversifie un peu
ses productions agricoles?
- Ah oui! C'est en venant ici
qu'il a commencé... qu'il a
décidé de commencer à rentrer
dans l'industrie des cochons,
en voyant toutes les nouvelles
machines, puis le moins
d'ouvrage qu'il aurait fait.
Là, il peut s'occuper de ça
lui-même, sans les garçons
en tout.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pour les éleveurs, une
exposition, c'est l'occasion
de montrer ses plus beaux
animaux et de prendre part
à des concours. En 1981,
l'Expo de Saint-Hyacinthe
accueillait 200 000 visiteurs.
- Bien des citadins,
des gens de la ville, des gens
de Montréal, aiment à venir à
Saint-Hyacinthe. Ils trouvent
que c'est réellement de
l'agriculture.
- Ensuite, on a la ferme
Roxton Pond.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et ça vient de Roxton Pond!
- Les rubans, surtout chez
les éleveurs, sont souvent
la principale récompense
accordée par les foires.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Plusieurs expositions au pays
ont une longue histoire ancrée
dans notre passé agricole;
celle de Brome remonte à 1856.
(bêlement)
La COVID a forcé l'annulation
de plusieurs de ces rendez-vous
en 2020 et l'été à venir
s'annonce toujours incertain.
(bêlement